龙飞姐，
你老公走进你用了多久，
他上交财政大权的那一刻吧，
我是不是有点太那个啥了啊，
太实在了啊，
就跟你们都说实话，
就他上交财政大权那一刻，
他就走进了我的心里，
我都能记得住是哪天哪号，
哎呀，
他本来不太想交完了之后我就委屈啊，
我都跟你那么久了是吧，
你嗯，
就怎么怎么地的，
我就哭，
我哭的时候我还就是门我开着哭，
我门我不关门，
我就开着点门缝，
我就特委屈了，
上交财政大权啊什么的，
后来他心想可能也放弃抵抗了，
他就上交了财政大权，
然后那一刻他就走进了我的心里，
在我这里的话，
他上交财政大权于我而言，
他就是一个非常大的信号，
就表明他是要踏踏实实跟我过日子了，
那你踏踏实实跟我过日子，
我这人是吧？
咱也不能差事儿，
我也踏踏实实跟你过日子啊，
就这意思啊，
我俩都30好几了，
我俩那会儿处对象的时候都30好几了，
彼此都有点那个小九九，
有点小心思，
我感觉很正常啊，
他在上交财政大权的时候有点抵抗情绪，
那不也很正常吗？
龙菲姐，
你还哭，
我跟你说，
眼泪这个东西，
他不光是男人控制女人的最好的武器，
你好多男的，
他不是假装在你面前装可怜吗？
让你同情他吗？
激发你的母性吗？
激发你的保护欲吗？
激。
那你想成为那个世界上对他最好的人吗？
是吧，
眼泪这个东西，
它既是男人最好的控制女人的武器，
同时也是女人最好的能实现自己目标的武器啊，
真事儿，
菲姐，
男友给了实体卡吗？
不是直接转账给我，
还给什么实体卡呀，
就转账到我的卡里了，
就上交财政大权了，
从此之后我就踏踏实过日子啊，
我跟你说，
人就是这么奇怪，
原来的时候，
哎呀，
我过生日，
我想着是不是得给给我送个金镯子呀，
给我送个金坠子呀，
过什么520，
过什么七夕节的时候，
我想着他是不是得给我送个什么啊值钱的礼物呀什么的，
一旦他上交经济大全了之后，
从此之后我特别节俭，
我自己啥也不舍得买，
谁能懂我这个点？